okay I'm dr. Keller and if you're  getting ready for a big night of  drinking make sure you've been taking  your vitamins one of the best things you  can do to help prevent a hangover the  next day is take your antioxidants this  is vitamin C vitamin B these will help  snatch up all of the nasty breakdown  products of alcohol that your body's  gonna have to deal with and help  eliminate them faster so that you don't  have to deal with the horrible side  effects the next morning you can find  lots of B vitamins and C vitamins  over-the-counter or you can get them  from foods like citrus foods for vitamin  C or meat products cheese and dairy for  your B vitamins I'm dr. Keller and  there's a hangover prevention tip for  you